bom dia pessoal vocês estão prestes a
viver um momento que é um pouco
inusitado que eu tiver um vegan no vim
aqui falar sobre comer carne
esse assunto é alimentação é um assunto
superado gostoso certo todo mundo gosta
de comer ao mesmo tempo quando a gente
fala que o verdão vai falar sobre isso
todo mundo já fica com um pé atrás
parece que eu venho para apontar o dedo
na cara falar o que vocês estão fazendo
errado então eu quero começar
tranqüilizando todo mundo
eu não sou um ativista raivoso eu não
vim aqui para brigar com vocês eu sou
entusiasta da inovação e eu vim aqui
falar um pouco sobre como as tecnologias
de alimento transformando o mundo que a
gente vive e transformando a forma que a
gente faz a comida
eu quero começar a contar essa história
da alimentação e da criação de animais
mostrando como isso chegou na minha vida
e como isso se desenvolveu na minha
própria história
eu começo com essa foto eu sou nascido
na cidade de botucatu no interior de são
paulo
vocês já podem ter percebido isso pela
palestra sobre carne sede a minha
família era de comerciantes por parte de
pai
fazendeiros por parte de mãe essa foto
aqui atrás do meu avô
ele é o segundo da direita para a
esquerda está montado na sua égua
amazona em 2 de novembro de 1944
se eu posso abrir aqui um parêntese
sobre isso eu só sei dessas informações
porque alguém escreveu isso a lápis no
verso da foto
eu acho que é o dispositivo que eles
tinham para fazer o que hoje a gente faz
na legenda do instagram
faltou só um hash tags 'estou pra gente
saber o que ele estava indo fazer de
fato certo eo meu ro
nessa época na juventude dele ele era um
boiadeiro então ele trabalhava no
transporte de gado em uma fazenda em
outro não foi o único da nossa família
está envolvido com isso quase todos os
30 mãos dele chegaram a trabalhar em
alguma coisa desse mesmo setor e já deu
pra ver então algumas coisas sobre a
minha família certo
em primeiro lugar os almoços em casa
podem ser bem movimentados
vocês ficam reclamando que tem que
aguentar um tio no almoço de domingo que
é difícil marcar com todo mundo pro
natal então redefinir os seus conceitos
sobre o que é uma família grande
em segundo lugar dá pra gente vê o como
essa questão da criação de animais foi
importante o desenvolvimento da minha
família pensa que na hora que já estava
todo mundo tanta gente assim a única
solução de alimentação era fazer um
churrascão daqueles então eu fui criado
com alimentação mas brasileira e mais
tradicional que eu poderia ter sido
criado
ao mesmo tempo ao contrário do meu avô
eu nunca trabalhei no campo
eu me formei em administração de
empresas trabalha sentado atrás de uma
mesa na maior parte da minha vida e eu
tinha todo esse consumo de comer muita
carne com muita gordura e eu não tinha
um gasto calórico que eles tinham nessa
época para fazer a manutenção da fazenda
de novo já deu pra ver para onde essa
história começa a caminhar certo se a
gente pular de 1944 para 2015
esse aqui sou eu em primeiro lugar eu
admito que mostrava a minha paixão pela
carreira de um jeito bem esteticamente
contestável
mas o que estava por trás dessas fotos
era um quadro de obesidade que eu vivia
nessa época eu pesava quase 150 quilos e
eu tinha muitos problemas já associados
à minha saúde muitos problemas sociais
também ia desde você não sabe se vai
conseguir encontrar uma roupa que te
silva até chegar no restaurante não
saber se vai poder sentar-se na cadeira
desse restaurante aguentar então estava
sendo uma fase muito difícil pra mim e
os meus amigos meus familiares e médicos
entraram numa campanha para ter uma vida
mais saudável e eu resolvi tomar a
decisão de cortar os ingredientes de
origem animal da minha dieta
uma amiga minha tinha virado ver gana eu
achei que podia ser um jeito de me
forçar a ter novos hábitos e foi assim
que eu comecei muito mais buscando um
interesse na minha dieta da minha saúde
do que de fato entendendo todos os
impactos dessas minhas escolhas e aí
felizmente nos 15 meses que se seguiram
eu consegui perder 55 quilos e
orgulhosamente mostrar esse antes e
depois de mim mesmo
bastante coisa certa eu acho que não dá
para falar que essa dieta não fez bem
pra mim
ao mesmo tempo a coisa mais
diante disso foi perceber que essa dieta
não estava impactando só a mim mas uma
série de outros fatores a começar pelo
meio ambiente
então não venho aqui para discutir dados
no detalhe de como estão sendo os
impactos ambientais
mas hoje a gente sabe que a criação de
animais está por trás de vários impactos
ambientais que acontecem no mundo que
vão desde a emissão de gases de efeito
estufa
o uso intensivo da água o uso intensivo
do solo a degradação dos oceanos
então isso é uma questão super
importante que eu entendi como é minha
alimentação contribuiu para tal
em segundo lugar ao mesmo tempo que eu
estava lá sofrendo pelo excesso tinha
muita gente no mundo sofrendo pela falta
hoje quase 800 milhões de pessoas estão
passando fome
agora enquanto a gente conversa e no
cerne dessa questão dessa dificuldade de
alimentar o mundo tem o fato de que a
gente cria grãos para dar os animais e
depois como esses animais então pensa a
gente está aqui gastando nossa energia
fazendo o metabolismo
o animal é a mesma coisa um animal um
boi pode ser alimentado durante vários
anos de vida comigo uma vez só
eu trouxe aqui esses dois de conversão
que poderia ser diferente para cada
animal
mas quando a gente fala que a taxa de
conversão entre grãos ea caem final em
11 por cento significa que 90 por cento
das calorias que foram geradas pelo
nosso sistema de alimentação se perderam
no metabolismo desse animal e isso é um
problema para a gente hoje
por fim eu cheguei nas questões de
sofrimento animal e que a gente sabe que
as empresas não se preocupam tanto com
isso
mas ao mesmo tempo hoje as empresas se
preocupam com a opinião dos consumidores
cada vez mais uma pessoa consegue tirar
uma foto ou seja numa fazenda seja no
supermercado essa foto de um animal
sendo explorado vai pra mídia e causa um
problema grande para as empresas então
as empresas começaram a se preocupar com
isso
mas já estou quebrando a minha promessa
eu falei que eu tinha para falar de
solução certo de inovação
então a solução que eu tenho pra essa
história muito interessante essa aqui
o hambúrguer isso mesmo eu não tô
falando que vocês têm que sair daqui pra
enfiar a cara num prato de salada não se
você quiser eu apóio muito faz super
sentido é uma coisa super saudável
ao mesmo tempo se você mais apegado às
suas tradições alimentares assim como eu
era antigamente
talvez essa nossa solução seja sua praia
agora o que a gente está falando sobre
bill mimetizar ou seja replicar aquilo
que a natureza criou a partir de outras
técnicas
essa visão é a visão de que a gente pode
parar de encarar por exemplo um
hambúrguer como uma caixa preta como
carne e começar a encarar esse
hambúrguer como a sua composição seja em
fibras proteínas gorduras e essa visão
abre muitas portas porque é
perfeitamente possível a gente encontrar
uma proteína no mundo vegetal uma
gordura no mundo vegetal e usar essas
outras fontes de proteínas para replicá
aquelas que a gente tanto gosta de comer
e por isso chamaram as chamadas food tex
que são em surgiram as chamadas food
texas que são as empresas que estão
agregando a questão da tecnologia nesse
mercado tão tradicional da alimentação
elas estão tentando resolver os
problemas do mundo do jeito mais gostoso
possível que com comida não mais aquela
comidinha chata salada que vocês não
querem sair daqui pra comer no almoço
eles estão realmente fazendo a comida
que a gente quer comer através de outras
tecnologias e hoje já é possível
replicar quase tudo tenha seu hambúrguer
que parece totalmente carne mas na
verdade ele é feito de vegetais
você pode ter um frango empanado que na
verdade também foi feita a partir de uma
proteína vegetal tem gente usando tomate
para fazer o ato pelo xvii tem gente
fazendo camarão tudo isso à base de
plantas e uma das coisas mais
interessantes disse que o fato de que
uma indústria nascente para trazer novas
tecnologias não significa que a
indústria tradicional vai ser totalmente
destruída
ao contrário a indústria tradicional que
trabalha com animais é exatamente uma
das maiores investidoras desse setor e
faz sentido porque essa indústria já tem
a cadeia de distribuição já conhece os
clientes já tem a logística porque não
há lugar mais um tipo de produto nessa
estrutura e se rentabilizar com isso a
gente se move daquela idéia de que uma
coisa tem necessariamente que nascer
para destruir quem estava lá e entra
numa ideia de que se todo mundo cooperar
e trabalhar em prol da tecnologia a
gente vai conseguir soluções para os
desafios que são aqui pra todos nós
e além da solução de carne de carne
vegetal
surgiu também uma outra solução chamada
carne limpa ou carne de origem celular é
a mesma coisa que a reprodução dos
órgãos que é feita por cientistas da
área de medicina
só que agora feito para carne parece
coisa de outro mundo mas os cientistas
já conseguiram tirar a célula de um
animal reproduzir essa célula e fazer a
carne sem precisar ter abatido o animal
coisas que já foram feitas então aqui a
gente tem uma carne de pato uma
almôndega feitas totalmente a partir
desse processo
a gente entra no detalhe da ciência em
outro momento até porque eu sou
administrador hinos o cientista
mas o processo basicamente seria de
isolar células de um animal colocar essa
célula dentro de um biorreator e
reproduzi ela com dos nutrientes
corretos quando as células se reproduzem
a gente adiciona um esquete food uma
estrutura de diferenciação andaime
pressa organizar o crescimento desse
tecido e no final das contas o produto
final é carne do mesmo jeito que a gente
está acostumado
se você pegar e colocar no microscópio
você vai ver uma célula animal mas
nenhum animal foi abatida para fazer
aquele produto é literalmente possível
comer um bife
olhando para o boi vivo na sua frente e
eu quero terminar essa história voltando
um pouco pra minha história pessoal
eu estava trabalhando há praticamente
sete anos na mesma empresa quando eu
comecei a entrar em contato com isso e
decidir que faria sentido pra mim me
envolver no instituto onde o trabalho
hoje que promove o desenvolvimento
dessas carnes celulares
isso foi pouco mais de dois anos atrás
eu fiz isso porque entende que apesar da
minha escolha pelo organismo ter sido
muito positiva tanto pra mim quanto para
outros fatores ainda faltava uma oferta
de produtos consistente onde as pessoas
pudessem simplesmente fazer essas
escolhas mais saudáveis mais
sustentáveis sem ter que mudar
completamente seus hábitos alimentares
porque a questão da alimentação não é só
uma questão de nutrição alimentação é a
coisa mais cultural que existe carrega
as nossas tradições nossas raízes mostra
quem foi a nossa família conecta gente
com outras pessoas
então precisa de uma oferta de produtos
que possa manter a cultura e mudar a
tecnologia
por isso entende que até
tecnologia de alimentos seria um dos
caminhos que a gente poderia usar para
salvar o mundo e faz sentido pra todo
mundo
quando eu comecei ninguém queria falar
comigo era aquele menino maluco que
estava falando que carne a ser feita a
partir de uma célula mas hoje menos de
dois anos depois esse assunto já saiu
das grandes revistas jornais o assunto
cresceu muito e por quê porque fez
sentido
as pessoas podem fazer uma escolha
alimentar quer mais ética mais aos da
saudável mais sustentável sem nem ter
que abrir mão do hamburgo de sexta feira
à noite isso então o início de uma nova
revolução e não é uma revolução que vem
para destruir uma revolução que vem para
transformar através da tecnologia e
fazer com que o sistema que existe hoje
consiga crescer de forma muito mais
sustentável crescer sim porque a gente
está falando que o mundo vai ter quase
10 bilhões de pessoas em menos de 30
anos
a gente não consegue nem alimentar todo
mundo que está aqui hoje imagina com
mais gente precisando de ainda mais
recursos é urgente investir nesse tipo
de tecnologia que possa dar acesso a
todos à alimentação e é por isso que
toda a sociedade se envolve tanto as
pessoas quanto as empresas quanto os
cientistas começam a ter uma área enorme
para investir nesse tipo de setor e eu
não poderia deixar de citar o governo
que também tem uma importância muito
grande para isso não só de regular esse
setor mas de promovê lo porque o brasil
hoje é uma potência agropecuária
se a gente investir nessa tecnologia a
gente tem tudo o que precisa para se
tornar um líder global dessa tecnologia
no futuro a gente já tem conhecimento
base para isso no nosso país
hoje em dia então quando você escolhe um
produto como esse quando vocês olham
para o hambúrguer não enxerga e só não
vejo um lanche uma refeição almoço ou
jantar
vejam com o incrível é o fato de que
vocês vão viver uma das mudanças mais
importantes da história da humanidade
vocês vão ver carne sendo feita de
plantas vocês vão ver caixa sendo feito
a partir de células sem precisar bater
nenhum animal e é uma das primeiras
mudanças que vêm exatamente para não
mudar porque isso é uma tecnologia para
que você possa continuar comendo
exatamente a coisa que você gosta de
comer
é um cenário onde o planeta vai ter
muito mais gente não é mais sobre
desenvolver produtos para o mercado de
nicho de vegetarianos
agora é um esforço e um esforço conjunto
de toda a sociedade para desenvolver as
tecnologias que vão nos permitir
alimentar o mundo do futuro sejam bem
vindos ao futuro da comida e muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]